-With a few exceptions,
Republicans have made clear
that they're willing
to excuse the behavior
of both former president
Donald Trump
and Georgia Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
Until now, it's been very clear
to me that Donald Trump
should face every legal
consequence imaginable
for trying to overthrow
the United States government.
He should be impeached,
convicted,
and barred from ever
holding office again.
His properties should be seized.
His golf courses
should be turned
into publicly protected
wetlands,
and his namesake son should be
banished to the woods
to live among the only creatures
who truly understand him,
the stumps.
King of the stumps!
But then Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham made a threat
so chilling, so harrowing,
I had to reconsider my position.
If Democrats choose to move
forward and call witnesses,
Graham said he'd have no choice
but to do something unthinkable,
investigate what happened.
-To my Democratic colleagues, if
you vote to call one witness --
none were called in the House --
get ready for a long trial.
If you open up
that can of worms,
we'll want the FBI to come in
and tell us about
how people actually preplanned
these attacks
and what happened
with the security footprint
at the Capitol.
You open up Pandora's box
if you call one witness.
-Yeah, because, famously,
when Pandora opened her box,
that's what came out --
useful information.
You hear him, Democrats?
Lindsey Graham is threatening
to make your life hell
by finding out
exactly what happened
and then making
those things public.
Ooh, you're not gonna like that,
Democrats.
Public accountability
for Donald Trump
and his accomplices?
I mean, what's next, witnesses,
evidence, consequences?
[ As Lindsey Graham ] You better
be careful, Democrats,
or I'll have no choice
but to get to the bottom
of what Donald Trump did and,
if necessary, convict him.
Is that what you want?
Donald Trump shuffling off
to prison in leg irons
never to be seen again?
Oh, you'll rue the day,
Democrats.
What's that, Meemaw?
I'm making a fool of myself?
The only fool here is you,
Meemaw!
I heard you got caught
shoplifting at the A&P again.
Meemaw!
Why don't you close
that dang music box
and quit smearing your lipstick
with your thumb?
[ Normal voice ] It's so
mind-boggling and bewildering
that Graham thinks proving
the attack was preplanned
somehow gets Trump off the hook.
It's like getting caught
standing over a dead body
holding a knife, saying,
"Officer, you don't understand.
I've had this knife for years."
It would actually be very useful
to have an in-depth trial
where every aspect of the
insurrection is investigated
in full view of the public,
because every day we learn more
about the events
leading up to it,
including details of Trump's
concerted months-long effort
to get the results
of the election overturned.
This week, Axios reported
stunning new details
about what they call
"the craziest meeting
of the Trump presidency,"
which is saying a lot given
he's also met with Ted Nugent,
Sarah Palin, Kanye West,
and a can of uncooked beans.
[ As Donald Trump ]
Do you know anything about
voter fraud, beans?
[ High-pitched voice ] Sí.
[ As Donald Trump ] You do?
[ Donald Trump ] What about you,
adobo seasonings?
[ Deep voice ] Alright.
[ Normal voice ]
Trump met with a group of
unhinged conspiracy theorists,
including Michael Flynn,
who has called for Trump
to use the military
to seize voting machines
and rerun the election,
effectively installing himself
as a military dictator,
and Sidney Powell,
the lawyer who faces
$1.3 billion defamation suit for
claiming the election was rigged
as part of an international
Communist plot,
including the late Venezuelan
president Hugo Chávez,
and who always looks
like she just got done
taking a sledgehammer
to James Caan's legs.
At one point during
this meeting, Powell...
A White House aide replied...
Powell replied...
[ Scoffs ]
You know you're far gone
when even Rudy hasn't caught up
to your insanity yet.
It's like being too abstract
for Picasso.
"Dalí, I'm all for having fun,
but clocks don't melt, my man."
Although the idea
that Rudy doesn't know
what the case is about
would not surprise me.
I'm sure walking Rudy
through a case
is like watching "Inception"
with your grandpa.
"A dream within a dream?
Okay, fancy pants.
Wake me up when the Allies
start bombing the Nazis.
That's my kind of movie."
So that's how this insane
this meeting was --
too insane for Rudy Giuliani.
A third insane person in
the meeting was Patrick Byrne,
the former CEO of overstock.com,
because why not?
They got MyPillow, Overstock.
All they need now to complete
the roster of business all-stars
is the CFO of Hollywood Video
and an actively on-fire
Samsung Galaxy.
Now, all you need to know
for this next part
is that Byrne got into
a heated confrontation
with a White House official
named Eric Herschmann.
The White House Counsel,
Pat Cipollone,
was also in the room.
The best and the brightest,
folks.
These guys want everyone
to have voter I.D.
But they don't even
know the I.D.
of the person
they're talking to.
I can't believe I'm saying this,
but if Rudy had been there
for that part of the meeting,
his presence would have actually
raised the average IQ level.
Though he would have
probably also yelled,
"Do you know who I am?"
and sincerely
meant the question.
[ As Rudy Giuliani ]
Do you know who I am?
Do you know where I am
in the month, please?
I keep my name
stitched in my suit,
but this is a loner jacket
from Del Frisco's!
Now I know how Scrooge felt --
confused!
I'm not Hugo Boss, am I?
[ Normal voice ] Trump is gone,
but that doesn't mean
we can just forget about
the crimes he committed,
the calamities he unleashed,
and the forces he exposed
because those forces
are at the very heart
of the modern Republican Party
and will be going forward,
as evidenced by Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene.
Greene has, among other things,
claimed school shootings
were staged,
suggested that Nancy Pelosi
should be executed for treason,
and said Muslims shouldn't serve
in government,
and yet GOP leaders in the House
have refused to sanction her,
forcing Democrats to move
forward with the resolution
revoking her
committee assignments.
Others have brushed
the controversy aside.
For example, Lindsey Graham...
Oh, sure, take her word for it.
[ As Lindsey Graham ]
Congresswoman Greene assured me
that while the posts were
on her Facebook page,
it's only because Bill Gates
gave her password
to the ghost of Hugo Chávez,
and that's good enough for me.
Meemaw, are you satisfied?
Meemaw, I will help you
with your corset,
but I'm telling you, there is
no colonel coming over tonight!
Meemaw, that was a movie
we watched!
Not that one, Peepaw.
That was "Inception."
You two!
[ Normal voice ]
But the dumbest excuse
for refusing to condemn Greene
came from newly minted Alabama
senator Tommy Tuberville,
who is apparently
as dumb as his name.
Sounds like a cartoon jar
of mayonnaise
who tries to kidnap
the Veggie Tales.
Tuberville told CNN he hadn't
seen Greene's posts because,
and this is real, a real excuse,
the weather's been bad.
Look, I really
don't want to repeat
any negative stereotypes
about the South,
but you're not doing Alabama
any favors when, as a senator,
you claim you can't watch the
news because of the weather.
Do you still are have
rabbit ears on your TV?
[ Southern accent ] I haven't
looked at what she's done
because the gossipy polecat
who tells me the news
has been hibernating.
[ Normal voice ] Also,
I love when these dopes
can't even get to the finish
line on their own bull[bleep]
and then just give up at the end
and say "whatever."
[ Southern accent ]
I meant to look at my phone,
but the battery was dead.
Or I dropped it in the toilet.
Or [Stammering] whatever.
[ Normal voice ]
But I have to say, the most vile
defense of Greene I saw today
came from Republicans
on Fox News,
which repeatedly
tried to equate her
with Minnesota congresswoman
Ilhan Omar,
including this comment
from Bill Hemmer.
-What she's doing is of a whole
different kettle of fish.
-One might be weird and kooky,
Josh.
The other is seen as racist.
-Hmm, let's see,
one wants Medicare for all
and the other thinks a Jewish
space laser starts wildfires.
Seriously,
what's wrong with you?
There's no equivalence,
and any attempt to create one
is disgusting and racist.
Greene has refused to apologize,
despite sharing anti-Muslim
and anti-Semitic posts
questioning whether a plane
really crashed into the Pentagon
on 9/11,
suggesting that school shootings
were fake,
that Nancy Pelosi
should be executed,
that Barack Obama
is a secret Muslim,
that Muslims
shouldn't be allowed
to serve at all
in the government,
and, once again, that a Jewish
space laser starts wildfires.
That's way beyond
weird and kooky.
She's not a member
of the Addams Family,
unless Uncle Fester believed
that a Jewish space laser
starts wildfires.
It's not your crunchy aunt
who's into Reiki and crystals
and sews birds
onto all her sweaters.
"Before we sit down
for Thanksgiving dinner,
allow me to sage the room
and cleanse our auras, namaste."
"Connie, your boob is out.
Aunt Connie, your boob,
it's in the casserole."
This is the bad-faith
bull[bleep]
that right-wing media
is full off
because they have nothing else.
It's a movement
that is fully radicalized
against pluralistic,
multiracial democracy,
and now the right-wing media's
cannibalizing itself
as they compete to appeal
to the far-right fringe.
There's no better example
of that
than what happened on Newsmax,
which has tried to outflank
Fox News on the far right.
They invited on
the MyPillow guy,
who, you might remember,
has also claimed the election
was hacked by China
and walked into the Oval Office
for a meeting with Trump
holding notes that said
"martial law" on them.
Newsmax was just trying
to get Lindell
to complain
about cancel culture,
not repeat his election fraud
lies, but then this happened.
-What happened with your Twitter
account and the company page?
-Well, first mine was taken down
because we have
all the election fraud
with these Dominion machines.
We have 100% proof.
And then when they
took it down...
-Mike. Mike.
-And then I put it back up,
my personal, I put a --
-Mike, thank you very much.
Mike, Mike, you're talking
about machines that --
We at Newsmax
have not been able to verify
any of those kinds
of allegations.
We wanted to talk to you about
canceling culture, if you will.
We don't want to relitigate
the allegations
that you're making, Mike.
Could you make an argument
that this could be
a temporary banning
rather than permanent?
-No, I want it to be a permanent
because you know what?
They did this because I'm
revealing all the evidence
on Friday of all of the election
fraud with these machines.
So I'm sorry if you think
it's not, but it's real.
-Can I ask our producers,
can we get out of here, please?
I don't want to have to
keep going over this.
-We at Newsmax have not
been able to verify
any of those allegations
that you're --
-Mike, hold on a second.
Everybody hold on a second.
Mike, Mike, hold on one second.
Let's talk a little bit --
-Oh...my...pillow.
Usually you see the guests
storm off but never the anchor.
Where do you even go after that?
That's like trying to storm out
of a meeting in your own office.
"This is bull[bleep]
And I hate this job and I quit!
Could you guys
maybe take this meeting
down to the conference room?"
Also, I got to ask,
does MyPillow actually work?
Because this guy looks like
he hasn't slept in a year.
Is MyPillow
just a bag full of rats?
You need to sleep, Mike.
"Who can sleep with all that
infernal scratching!"
He always looks like he was
just chased by Da Bears!
[ Laughter ]
Also, this segment
is so revealing,
because instead of focusing
on the actual content
of what Lindell is supposedly
being canceled for,
they just want him to say
the words "cancel culture,"
and he won't go along.
It shows how empty
their cancel-culture
talking points are.
They complain that free speech
is being suppressed,
and then once he starts saying
something they don't like,
they try to suppress his speech.
It's like taking your toddler
to an adult dinner party
and saying to him, "Hey,
remember, you say thank you,
you say please,
and that's it, okay?"
And then the second you walk in
the door, he immediately shouts,
"Mommy caught Daddy following
the babysitter on Instagram!"
We are facing multiple
simultaneous crises
that have created
misery and suffering
for millions of Americans
with a botched vaccine rollout,
an economic crash, and poverty
and child hunger on the rise.
We need a political system
that can respond urgently
to those crises.
Instead we have
one political party
radicalizing against democracy,
siding with seditionists
and bigots.
It's almost as if,
in a desperate bid for power
at any cost,
the GOP was willing to...
-Open up Pandora's box.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
Wear a mask. We love you.